the Geoghan experience this happens all
the time there's like something happens
in the news for the political candidates
running for president it's who can get
their tweet out the fastest on the issue
we saw this recently with the situation
in Syria with the Kurds and who can get
the tweet out the fast people are asking
me like hey what do you have to say what
do you have to say I'm like I'm trying
to understand the situation first I'm
actually trying to understand what
happened and why we are in the situation
that we're in once I do that I'll let
you know what I think and that was
another one of those end-of-the-world
scenarios that unfolded you know we
Trump hold the troops out of out of that
area and it was like oh the world's
gonna end and look there was some bad
stuff that happened I get it some Isis
folks as folks some Isis terrorists
murderers escaped I got that some some
Kurds were killed like some bad stuff
happened but it wasn't the end of the
world and and one thing you know I was
at my second deployment to Iraq we were
we started doing counterinsurgency
operations instead of counter-terrorist
operations so we we changed our strategy
and as we did this we were we were
starting to kill a decent amount of bad
guys a bad of these insurgents so a few
weeks go by and I got a message from up
my chain of command and they're like hey
joko we get that you're doing these
missions but right now we're not seeing
any changes in the metrics as far as
enemy attacks that are happening
happening right and luckily I had read
the counterinsurgency manual that was
written by General Petraeus and and I
part of that explains that a the average
counterinsurgency takes seven years to
work itself out right and so I said hey
you know boss the average
counterinsurgency takes seven years to
to flush itself out it's only been three
weeks
can I get support for some more time
here to work through this and he's like
okay yeah you know makes sense but my
point is it's the same thing here we
think that some news event that we can
fully understand a news event within one
hour of it happening we don't have any
understanding we you need to let these
things to
and and see where the actual long-term
effects are we can't be snapping
judgments and making radical decisions
or split decisions when we have to
actually assess what is really going on
and so that the press for sure is like
snap precision snap decision snap
position and you can see it's comical to
flip back and forth between the two to
the left-wing media in the right-wing
media and one of them is the greatest
this is never another one's the most
horrible thing has ever happened and
there you go and you know no one can
even make an assessment of what just
happened cuz it only happened 14 minutes
ago
how about we see where it plays out it's
about being first rather than actually
being accurate and presenting the
American people with here's what has
gone on you can form your own opinion
you can form your own conclusion but
here's the course of events that took
place ABCD and E and that's that's
exactly what we're missing in in most of
the time I think it's what we're talking
about earlier I think we're poisoned by
this desire to have our information fed
to us very quickly and the the fact that
there's so much information coming at us
we don't have enough time to sit back
and read a manual on how long it takes
counterinsurgency efforts to be fruit
fruition to reach fruition the the fact
that that's hitting you in the military
that you would think that the most
pragmatic the most disciplined people
that understand the long game that are
playing 3d chess those are the people
that you would want telling people like
you what you can and can't do the fact
that that kind of thinking is even
filtering down to Special Ops groups is
crazy well what's nice is we do have
decentralized command inside the
military so when I'm telling my boss
this what's going on my boss doesn't
like shut up and do what I told you to
do my boss like okay make sense explain
it to me okay got it yeah that makes
sense cool move forward that's that's a
very positive thing in the military
everyone thinks that the military is
this rigid structured way where you just
obey the chain of command you don't you
don't fear from that at all but if my
boss tells me to do something that
doesn't make any sense I'm gonna say hey
boss this actually was a bad plan we
should do it a different way and if I
have a good boss my boss says oh okay I
didn't see that angle and that's another
thing that you know when Tulsi is
talking about how politicians we come up
with a plan and then we start executing
the plan guess what once you start
executing a plan some other things are
gonna come to come to light right and
you as a leader have to say hey you know
what
started executing this it's going pretty
good but I didn't foresee this happening
I'm making an adjustment here it is
here's what we're gonna do and I'm gonna
wait for that feedback to come to me the
promised people are so insecure or slash
their egos so big that they won't
they'll just I just going to stick with
the same plan no matter everyone else is
dumb no do you need to see it through
it's like no actually we need to make
some changes because they you know they
are afraid of saying hey my initial
assessment might have been inaccurate or
wrong yeah and and I think that that
also just points the bigger point for
the political leadership the civilian
leadership that sets the policy that the
military executes is so often lacks that
foresight and that that planning of
actually looking okay if we pursue
course of action a you know we call here
will be the second third fourth order of
effects right here's how you know the
enemy or the opponent is likely to react
or here's how other actors are likely to
react to our action so we can try to
anticipate that and then we can okay
this is how we would respond this is how
they're likely to respond actually go
through this so that we don't end up in
the situation that we too often find
ourselves in where you're like alright
here's the here's the mission guys go
for it and then you whether it's a week
or a month or a year later like hey how
the hell do we find ourselves here it's
like you failed as leaders the leaders
of our country failed to ask those
questions about you know what happens
what happens next you know after we go
in and topple Saddam Hussein and we
completely obliterate the entire Iraqi
military what actually happens next what
will be the consequences to this what
will be the cost to our troops our
military what will be the cost to the
Iraqi people what will be the cost to
American taxpayers is the is the object
do we know what the objective is is it
achievable
what's our end state an exit strategy
when you look back and I've just I've
seen this throughout my seven years in
Congress sitting on the Foreign Affairs
Committee sitting on the Armed Services
Committee where we're questioning and
providing oversight over the Department
of Defense and Department of State
asking leaders these questions and when
were not given answers or given
ambiguous answers or things like you
know I asked secretary mattis once in a
hearing about how al-qaeda has gotten so
strong
in Syria too where I mean right now they
they control an entire city the entire
city of Idlib is controlled by al-qaeda
and I asked him at that time I said why
aren't we going after al-qaeda in Syria
in a very serious and concerted way and
his answer was well it's complicated
it's complicated and it's it's it it's
frustrating to say the least but I think
it's been a very transmits been a very
clear window into the lack of foresight
and good judgment and just the ability
to look at these challenges and
situations with that that basic
understanding in a non-emotional way and
understand what's the objective cost and
consequences before we launch this
action
[Applause]